time to cover the afc south as we enter
the final days preceding the draft the
four teams in that division have needs
let's go one at a time chris the colts
cannot leave the 2020 draft without what
well i i think the position that jumps
out to me defense pretty well built we
know the offensive line defensive line
pretty good depth there good talent
you know i look at them right now i
think it's between for for me i would go
wide receiver tight end and i think if
you pinned me down i would go wide
receiver you know i i i think that and
again they don't have a first round pick
so they're going to have to figure this
out but with t y hilton get up there in
years paris campbell who they drafted in
the second round last year you know kind
of being unproven uh to this point you
know devon functions they lost him in
free agency they have zach pascal who's
good but just a role receiver you know
so to me that would be one i would think
that chris ballard and the colts think
about somewhere in the second third
maybe middle of the draft regardless
to bolster that position and find a
little more depth and talent to improve
that wide receiver room
and anytime that subject comes up the
words that echo in my brain came last
week from eric decos to the ravens gm
when he said in the fifth round this
year you can find a starting receiver
that's how many great receivers there
are entering the draft and you're right
that's an area of need eric ebron left
via free agency to pittsburgh tight end
is an area of need i want to throw one
out there that we're going to maybe
touch on this a little bit more next
hour when we talk about the next running
backs to get paid because not every
running back that has generated a
thousand yard season early in his career
is going to get paid some teams may say
no thanks we'll draft somebody young and
cheap with full traffic tires and i
wonder where marlon mack falls into that
category of do we pay him or do we say
see you later because if they're going
to say see you later now's the year to
get the replacement because mac's
entering his contract year
yeah well there's no doubt and i would
think that chris ballard would be that
one of those type of guys that we talked
about yesterday looking at the shelf
life of a running back going you know
what every four years every three years
i need to just draft one somewhere in
the draft you know they have a little
depth at the position nahim heinz uh
jordan wilkins there at the running back
position but i mike i'm with you with
the running back thought i thought about
i like marlon mack i don't know if he's
definitely a big time starting tailback
in my opinion either so
i don't think that's a crazy thought
and remember the move that really
unlocked the colts
dynasty semi dynasty was when they
drafted edgar and james not that he was
still there when they finally won a
super bowl but he was a huge piece of
that puzzle to complement peyton manning
and marvin harrison and eventually
reggie wayne
when uh when james arrived back in 1999.
all right the houston texans who do not
have a first round pick do not have a
second round pick or at least one of
their second round picks now they picked
up a second round pick in the andre
hopkins trade they gave up a second
round pick to get brandon cooks they
can't leave the draft without what
well it has to be a front seven player i
i think that's the thing that i look at
right off the bat and go gotta be done
you know j.j watt up there in years dj
reader gun and free agency all right so
i'm gonna say a defensive lineman is the
most important thing to them i'm just
gonna keep it broad there i don't care
if it's an edge guy or somebody in the
middle but you know this is a team
that's lost clowny you know i talked
about merciless getting up there who who
were who are some of the young studs on
the texans defense you know that that's
a big question for me down there in
houston right now and billy o'brien the
gm yeah he's got some holes to fill in
that roster certainly but i look at it
more than anything depth and just talent
they need the defensive line position
they really probably need a little of
everything d tackle dn need it all
you know you've suggested in the past
the possibility of jadavian clowney
working his way back to houston as no
one seems to be interested in him he's
been lingering in free agency for weeks
if they don't come out of the draft with
that help maybe that makes a reunion
more likely i'm gonna flip it back to
the receiver position and eric decosta's
prediction you can get a starter in
round five
all due respect to brandon cooks that
does not replace deandre hopkins they
still have a gap there and you know one
of the things chris that that i'm gonna
be paying close attention to that 57th
overall pick in the draft that was sent
to the rams for brandon cooks what do
the rams do with it do they take a
receiver and boy that receiver in
comparison to cooks that's the guy the
texans could have had instead of cooks
for a lot less money or whichever
receivers are still on the board at
number 57 that the texans could have had
for a lot less money and how much would
a team get out of that guy how much does
a team get out of that guy who's
available at pick number 57 i still have
concerns about giving up that pick and
the slot the low value lo not high value
but low pay slot that goes along with it
instead of paying brandon cooks with his
concussion history and everything else i
they got they need to come out of this
with a young receiver that will make
people forget that they gave up a shot
at getting a very good young receiver to
get brandon cooks well i mean i i hear
you there's a lot of logic there they
need to find another receiver too just
in case like what you know you're right
not only deandre hopkins thing but
if brandon cooks gets another concussion
in week four
everyone's gonna go you idiot what were
you doing of course he gets concussions
you know that that's
that to me was
the the lost in translation there
fact of that trade the fact that you
know a guy like that commanded that much
in a trade where the next time he goes
over the middle it might be the end of
his career that's where i was a little
surprised he fits the offense cooks and
what they want to do but you're right
they need another guy there because you
know really two out of their three
starting receivers have injury history
brandon cooks and will fuller as we both
know are have been on you know on the
bench a lot because of injuries the last
few years so i i think your wide
receiver thought has a lot of merit
will fuller a first round pick in 2016.
he missed
five games last year was hurt all year
long and even when he did play there was
a question whether or not he was going
to be able to play constant hamstring
problems and you know as as you've said
when it's the hamstring that means
there's something else going on and
maybe they finally figured it out who
knows when he played last year he played
very well he had a career-high 670
receiving yards but that's not the kind
of stuff that screams out number one
receiver especially if you're not
playing in all the games the year before
that he only played in seven games a
year before that he only played in 10
games he has not been able to stay on
the field and so they need to have more
bodies they need to have guys they can
turn to because deshawn watson needs
people to throw to and now the new
security blanket's gone and deandre
hopkins what the hell is he gonna do
chris they have to fill up that position
no they do you're right and i mean at
face value the starting three look
really really good and that message
meshes well with the offense they want
to run you know they could send all
three deep cooks is a great route runner
to do a lot of the julian edelman
underneath stuff for that new england
type offense which billy o'brien runs so
it makes sense in theory but risky for
sure uh with those two guys in their
injury history your season could be
derailed in a hurry if two of those go
down in the first four or five weeks so
you better get some death depth of the
position
tennessee titans who made it to the
final four last year and had a ten point
lead twice in the first half at kansas
city they can't leave the draft without
what
well i i mean i look at them and i look
at really the defensive side of the ball
more than anything you know the
offensive line yes they lost jack
conklin we know that they got good
running back aj brown a receiver you
know so they're okay on the offensive
side of the ball i look at the defensive
i'm gonna go with the defensive line
once again i'm gonna go with the edge
like a you know
defensive end outside linebacker type
you know that's what they need you know
i really should just say defensive
lineman in general but they need a front
severand difference maker they got
jeffrey simmons who they drafted in the
first round last year a defensive tackle
they're expecting big things for him
that's why they traded jarrell casey but
you know great defenses super bowl
defenses
you need another marquee player on that
defensive line somewhere and to me
that's where they're missing like harold
landry's nice coming off the edge i know
they signed vic beasley but i'm not
going to put all my eggs into the oh
he'll get after the quarterback and get
10 sacks no he's been very inconsistent
as a pass wrestler through his career so
you know and it's only a one-year deal
so i go edge rusher there in tennessee
uh somebody to get after the quarterback
a little bit they got to replace jack
conklin though at right tackle i mean
they didn't pick up the option on
conklin last year he had some injury
issues he got it together and had a big
contract year parlayed that into a big
contract with the cleveland browns oh
well now they got a hole one of their
starting five is gone and yeah you can
always say next man up but you still
need bodies and you need to have guys
who provide depth whoever you push up
you have to backfill and you need to
have healthy
offensive linemen and capable offensive
linemen or you're not going to keep your
quarterback healthy and capable and
they've gone all in with ryan tannehill
who managed to stay healthy last year
but we know based on his history there
are times when he does not the jaguars
they can't leave the draft without what
well
you know similar here
to the rest of the division
you know
you lose yannick and gakwe dante fowler
in the last two years you know telvin
smith retired you know i look at you
know oh okay man they need some
defensive linemen but i think the more
overarching thing that worries me about
their roster is the cornerback position
that's the most underwhelming thing on
their roster so i look at that where
you've lost jaylen ramsey and aj bouier
you go man that's it's not easy to
replace that group right there and right
now hey they have some nice players some
guys that have kind of been career
journeymen but they don't have a marquee
guy that they can say hey go
go cover brandon cooks on third and five
and get all over him or you know go go
cover t.y hilton on fourth and five and
we need you to lock him down they have
nothing like that so to me the
cornerback position at some point in
this draft has to be addressed you know
not only to find quality players to play
but also they need just depth at the
position they don't have enough corners
on their football team in general right
now
you know it's funny not long ago there
was kind of a consensus it wasn't across
the board but people who who got it knew
that ramsay and bouier were the best two
in football now they're both gone ramsay
basically
dug his feet in the in the ground and
and uh finally got a trade and then they
just they they pulled the plug on
bouillee out of the blue and shipped him
off to denver and now they're starting
over again and look you mentioned
you mentioned in goku and gawkway's
still there but he wants out and the
thinking is they're going to make a move
maybe before the draft during the draft
they're gonna have to replace him so for
me it's edge rusher because then gawkway
is going to be gone they're going to
need to find somebody in the draft who
can fill his place on the roster chris
yeah that i mean it's definitely an
important position they play that
seattle defensive scheme we know you
need guys that can come off the edge now
they got josh allen in the first round
last year but i hear you you know that's
it's important they need to get there
with the front four in that seattle
scheme that's what they do so it makes a
lot of sense and mike jacksonville's
fascinating you know they they they're
kind of in a rebuild mode and it's just
amazing and it shows you in the nfl they
went from having one of the most
talented rosters in football two or
three years ago where you went wow look
at this squad and all this young talent
they have
and you know it just all went sideways
uh the last two years and things got
really thrown out of whack there and now
look at them now they're kind of in a
rebuild mode down in jacksonville
and it's strange because they're one of
the only teams in football that we look
at it and say they're rebuilding but
their owner may say i don't care i have
high expectations for this season and i
think he wants to see something that
will give him confidence in sticking
with coach doug marone and gm dave
caldwell beyond 2020
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports